JOEL LEWIS: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
You've been doing some
work on trig integration.
I have a nice example
here of a problem
that requires trig
integration in order to solve.
So what I'd like you to do is to
compute the volume of the solid
that you get when you take one
hump of the curve y equals sine
a*x and you revolve
it around the x-axis.
So you take the curve between
two consecutive roots,
and then you, you know,
revolve that around the x-axis
and that gives you
some, I don't know,
vaguely football-shaped thing.
And so then the
question is, what's
the volume of that solid?
So why don't you pause the
video, take a little while
to work that out, come back,
and we can work it out together.
Welcome back.
In order to solve
this problem, we just
are going to apply
our usual methods
for computing a volume
of a solid of rotation.
So in order to do that, remember
that one of the things you need
is you need to know the region
over which you're integrating,
and you need to choose
a method of integration.
So in this case,
looking at this region,
here, I'm rotating
it around the x-axis.
It looks to me-- so
we have two choices.
We could do shells with
horizontal rectangles,
or we could do disks
with vertical rectangles.
Looks to me like
vertical rectangles
are going to be the way
to go for this function.
Nice, simple, have their
base on the x-axis.
You know, this is a
nice setup for disks.
So we're going to take
vertical disks here, like this.
Vertical rectangles
that are going
to spin into vertical disks.
And so we're going to
integrate all these disks,
we're going to add them
up starting at x equals 0,
and going until the
end of this region.
So we need to figure out what
the end of that region is,
so we need sine
a*x to be 0, again.
Well, the first 0, the first
time sine is 0 after 0 is
at pi, so we need a*x to be pi.
So this value is at pi over a.
OK.
So that's the setup
for the problem.
And now we just need
to remember, you know,
how to do a problem like this.
So we have each of these disks.
Well, its height
here is the height
of the function, which
is y, in this case.
So the area of a
little disk-- sorry.
The area of a disk,
the little-- oh, dear.
The element of volume, the
little bit of volume that we
get is equal to-- well, the area
of the disk is pi y squared,
which is pi sine squared of a*x.
And then the thickness of
the disk is a little dx.
So this is our little
element dV of volume.
And now to get the
whole volume, we just
integrate this over
the appropriate range.
So this means V is equal to the
integral from 0 to, as we said,
to pi over a of pi times
sine squared of a*x dx.
So this is just like
the sorts of integrals
you were doing in class.
It's a definite integral.
I guess most of the ones you
did were just anti-derivatives,
but of course, that's
an easy translation
to make by via the
fundamental theorem.
So, OK, so we have
this a*x here.
You know, it's up to you.
I think my life will be
simpler if I just make a little
u-substitution,
get rid of the a*x,
and then I don't have to think
about it very much anymore.
So I can take u equals
a*x, so du equals a*dx,
or dx equals 1 over a du.
So I, OK, so I make
this quick substitution.
When x is 0, u is also 0.
When x is pi over
a, u is just pi.
So this becomes
the integral from 0
to pi-- I can pull
this pi out front.
And I can pull-- so I'm going
to get pi times sine squared
u times dx is 1 over a du.
So I'm going to pull the 1
over a out front, as well.
So it's pi over a times the
integral from 0 to pi of sine
squared u du.
OK.
So now we've just simplified
it to the situation where
we've just got a trig integral,
no other complications at all.
How do we do this one?
Well, OK, so this is not
one of those nice ones
where we have an odd power
for either sine or cosine.
We have sine is appearing
to the even power of 2,
and cosine, well,
it doesn't appear.
It appears to the even
power 0, if you like.
You could say it that way.
So when we have
a situation where
sine and cosine both appear in
even powers, what we need to do
is we need to use one
of our trig identities.
We need to use a
half angle identity.
So the identity in particular
that we want to use
is we want to replace sine
squared u with something
like a cosine of 2u somehow.
So in order to do that,
we need to remember
the appropriate identity.
So one of the double angle
identities is cosine of 2t
equals 1 minus 2
sine squared t, which
we can rewrite as the half angle
identity sine squared t equals
1 minus cosine 2t over 2.
So this is true for any value t.
In particular, it's true
when t is equal to u.
Back over here.
So we can rewrite this by
replacing sine squared u
with 1 minus cosine
of 2u divided by 2.
So this integral becomes, so
our integral is equal to-- well,
we've still got the pi over a
in the front-- integral from 0
to pi of 1 minus
cosine of 2u over 2 du.
OK, and so now we integrate it.
So 1 over 2, that's easy.
That's just-- so, OK, so the pi
over a is still out in front.
1 over 2 integrates,
just gives us u over 2.
How about cosine of 2u?
Well, so minus
cosine of 2u, so that
should give us a minus sine.
Right?
Derivative of sine is cosine,
derivative of minus sine
is minus cosine.
So its minus sine of 2u,
and then because it's 2u,
we're going to have
to divide by 2 again.
So over 4.
All right.
If you don't believe
me, of course,
you could always check by
differentiating this expression
and making sure that it matches
that expression, the integrand,
here.
And OK, and so we need
to take that between u
equals 0 and u equals pi.
So luckily we changed
our bounds of integration
and we don't have to go all
the way back to x again.
OK, so this is pi
over a times-- OK,
so u over 2 minus sine, 2u
over 4 when u is pi over 2
minus sine of 2 pi.
That's just 0, right?
Yes, that's just 0.
Good.
So this term is just 0.
pi over 2 minus-- OK, now
when we put in 0, here,
well, we get 0 minus sine
of 0, so that's just 0-- so
just pi over 2.
OK.
So the answer, then,
is pi squared over 2a.
So that's the volume
we were looking for.
So just to quickly recap, we
have our solid of revolution
here that we get by spinning
this region around the x-axis.
We use our typical methods
for computing volumes
of solids of revolution.
We've got a, when we do that,
the integral that we set up
is a trig integral with
a sine squared in it.
So both sine and cosine
appear to an even power
in this trig integral.
When you're in that
situation, you're
going to have to use your
half angle formulas, like so.
Once you do that,
you'll simplify.
Sometimes life is hard, you'll
have to do it more than once.
In this case, we only
had to do that once,
so we got-- then
we-- that reduces
the integral to something
that's easy to compute,
where you have one
of sine or cosine
always appearing
to an odd power.
In this case, very simple.
You just had a cosine.
And then you integrate it,
and this was our final answer.
I'll end there.